- Welcome, everyone,
we have the pleasure today
of having Professor Elena Fiddian-Qasmiyeh
from University College London,
she is the professor in
Migration and Refugee Studies
at the Geography Department
in, at UCL, in the UK.
She's the co-director of the
UCL Migration Research Unit
and is the founder and director
of the Institute of Advanced Studies,
Refugee in a Moving World
research network across UCL.
So Professor Qasmiyeh she
has a vast experience,
focusing
on the study of the refugees
and the intersection between
gender generation and religion
in context of conflict
induced displacement
with a particular focus on the
Middle East and North Africa.
She has conducted extensive
research in refugee camps
and urban areas included the
Nigeria, Cuba, Egypt, France,
Jordan, Lebanon, South Africa,
Syria, Sweden and the UK.
Drawing on a critical
theoretical perspective,
her work contributes to key debates
surrounding refugees experiences
of conflict induced displacement,
the nature of refugee (murmurs) relation
and both North-South and
South-South Humanitarian Responses
to forced migration.
Her current research
examines Southern responses
to displacement from Syria,
including responses developed
by local host communities
and refugee themselves.
So let's welcome
Professor Fiddian-Qasmiyeh
and she will be first
giving her presentation
and then she will be taking
questions at the end.
- Wonderful, thank you so much
for your very warm words of welcome
and thank you for inviting
me, thanks to all of you
for joining the session.
I know that there are many
competing demands on your time
so I'm very glad to see
so many names in squares
on my screen.
So today I'm going to
be speaking on the topic
of "Refugee-led Responses
to Overlapping Precarities",
focusing on a particular
refugee camp in North Lebanon
and in so doing, I'll be
drawing on two articles,
which are themselves based
on longstanding research.
So these articles were
published last year,
firstly in the Journal
of Palestine Studies,
which focuses in particular
on the evolving situation
with reference to coronavirus,
COVID-19 from March to June
in Baddawi Refugee Camp in North Lebanon
and the second piece,
which has co-authored
with Yousif Mustafah Qasmiyeh,
who was himself born
in Baddawi Refugee Camp
as an article that was
published in Current History
and focuses in part
on the events surrounding
the post-Beirut blast
in August, 2020 and again,
how this has affected people
who've experienced
displacement and are responding
to overlapping crises effectively
in their neighborhoods.
These articles are themselves informed
by longstanding research
as I've mentioned,
including two research
projects, "Refugee Hosts"
and "Southern Responses to Displacement",
which I've been leading since 2016
with a team of colleagues,
researchers in Lebanon, Jordan
and Turkey, as well as in Europe
and which have been
exploring how people, groups,
organizations in the Middle
East amongst other places
have been responding to
displacement from Syria since 2011.
And as I hope is increasingly
recognized by now,
far from being passive
recipients of humanitarian aid,
people who have experienced displacement
are themselves always already
finding ways to respond
to the challenges that they face
and also to help others
in the same situations.
And in those projects, "Refugee Hosts"
and "Southern Responses to Displacement",
we start from the premise
that the residents of neighborhoods,
which are hosting refugees,
have often experienced displacement
and forced migration
in the past themselves
and indeed may well face
displacement again in the future.
So this effectively means
that people who are currently
labeled as refugees, were,
are and will be hosts
and the ways that histories
of displacement intersect
with histories of hosting,
have important implications
for both the present and the future.
And in my research, this
means increasing attention
to different forms of
refugee-refugee relationality,
which is a term that I use to
explore these relationships
between people who have
been, been displaced
and that includes a focus on
refugees, hosting refugees
and on a broader range
of refugee-led responses
to displacement and indeed their responses
to more than displacement.
And there's focus on the
more than displacement,
I think is important
for a number of reasons.
And this focus on the
refugee-refugee relationality
in the context of displacement
and more than displacement,
is important because it's solely focusing
on and providing aid to
newly displaced people
or people who have just
experienced a crisis
in the short term as it
were, can discriminate
against those who are living
in protracted situations
of displacement, whose vulnerability
may increase over time.
And this is one of the key challenges
that I think that we face
when policy and practice
is often characterized
by what we can call a present test bias
that is only focusing on and responding
to the new crisis situation
rather than thinking more
carefully about intersecting
and overlapping forms of precarity.
So when we think about these
overlapping precarities
and the increasing vulnerability
over time, unfortunately
the situation in Lebanon
demonstrates this very clearly.
So we can start by noting of course,
that displacement from Syria to Lebanon
may have started in 2011
but of course takes place
on top of longstanding
protracted displacements
both internally and internationally.
When we then look at the events of 2020,
we see that these starkly
illustrate in the case of Lebanon,
the ways that vulnerabilities
can be accentuated
by intersecting crises, such
as the COVID-19 pandemic,
which has afflicted
the country since March
and which has led to a range of xenophobic
and discriminatory responses,
including discriminate,
discriminatory curfews on refugees,
politicians demanding camp
closures and falsely asserting
that refugees were vectors of
disease under the contagion
when in fact we know that
COVID-19 arrived in Lebanon
through Lebanese citizens
travel from Italy and around
but using this well-worn trope
of refugees as vectors of disease
to justify increased
surveillance and control
through these xenophobic
and discriminatory policies.
So on top of that, we then
have the devastating explosion
in Beirut's port on the
4th of August last year,
which was believed to have been
caused by an impounded cargo
of ammonium nitrate stored for
several years in a warehouse
without proper safety precautions.
And with major loss of life
and significant injuries,
alongside the destruction
to the port and the roads,
this has made the emergency
delivery of aid supplies
both very important but
also increasingly difficult
and international donors
started to send aid,
including medical supplies
and equipment to Lebanon
via the smaller Northern port of Tripoli,
which we'll be turning to shortly.
At that point, this is August
last year, at this point
the Lebanese Red Cross
headquarters announces
that all of the groups, hospital teams
in the North of the country
would be relocated to Beirut
due to a shift in priorities
and they were needed to
bolster medical capacity
to assess both blast survivors
and the dramatically increasing number
of COVID-19 patients in the Capitol.
So bearing that background in mind,
it's now to the coronavirus pandemic
that will turn, shifting from Beirut,
which has been the focus
of so much attention,
to a small and relatively
under researched,
urban refugee camp in North
Lebanon, called Baddawi Camp.
Baddawi Refugee Camp was
established in the early 1950s
and it is here that residents
have been supporting
both, in inverted commas,
old and new fellow refugees
who share the camp amidst
the multifaceted risks
created by the pandemic and by
the diverse responses to it,
responses that include unequal allocation
of and access to healthcare resources
in addition to anti-refugee
political reference,
rhetoric and policies.
So there are many ways
that we could introduce
Baddawi Refugee Camp
but here I'll draw on
Yousif M. Qasmiyeh's poem,
"Writing the Camp",
which I think captures
some of its key dynamics.
So he writes, "Refugees ask
other refugees, 'Who are you,
who are we to come to you and
who are you to come to us?'
Nobody answers, Palestinians,
Syrians, Iraqis, Kurds
share the camp, the same different
camp, the camp of a camp.
They've all come to
re-originate the beginning
with their own hands and feet".
And this reference to
re-originating the beginning
with their own hands and feet
is a very important reminder
that for many people
who've experienced
conflict and displacement,
they are always already in
the middle of displacement,
they have to re-originate the beginning
because it is a recurring process.
In the case of Baddawi Refugee Camp,
about 15,000 Palestinian refugees
who had previously been living
in the Nahr el-Bared
Refugee Camp in Lebanon,
were internally displaced too
and subsequently hosted in
Baddawi following the destruction
of Nahr el-Bared Camp in 2007.
This means that around 10,000
refugees from Nahr el-Bared,
are now part of the refugee
community in Baddawi Camp
who are hosting people who've
been displaced from Syria
and who are responding to
the needs and the rights
of the diverse residents of Baddawi Camp.
So here we have internally
displaced refugees,
hosted by refugees who are
themselves hosting refugees
and this is a very
important again, reminder
of the precarity of the
situations that people live in
but also these intersecting
processes of displacement
and of hosting and of the
multiple crises effectively
that people navigate
in their everyday lives
and in the lives of their families
and those who live around them.
Now, it was early in 2010
as the Coronavirus started to erupt
in different, different spaces
and in different guises,
that the residents of
Baddawi Camp themselves,
started to await with fear
for the arrival of COVID-19,
as Qasmiyeh writes in his
poem, "With a Third Eye,
I See the Catastrophe", so
I'll read his lines here,
"As we wait for the
disease, in echoless rooms,
doors locked up, shutters
dusted, thrust to the heart.
The disease that will sign
a pact with our diseases.
In patience bereft of patience,
we stand still behind our
walls: without seeing,
we shall see the disease that will be.
With a third eye, I see the catastrophe".
And this fear has been born
out by the UN statistics,
which in February of this year,
documented the Palestinians
COVID-19 mortality rate
is three times higher
than the mortality rate
for the country as a whole.
But importantly as we all
know, this increased risk,
this increased mortality risk,
is not because of displacement,
it isn't inevitable.
Instead, camp residents in
Lebanon are acutely vulnerable
to the impacts of COVID-19
because of, living in
overcrowded urban camps
with poor infrastructure,
many residents afflicted
with pre-existing health
conditions, have multiplied
and worsened over time due
to, amongst other things,
the fragile UNRWA health
systems, which have been defunded
and weakened over
decades by fickle donors,
while Lebanese health
systems have a long history
of discriminating against and
denying treatment to refugees.
So against this backdrop, it's
not surprising that mistrust
amongst Palestinians and
their fellow camp dwellers
towards international
and national aid agencies
and government departments,
has remained very high
as they have faced COVID-19,
which leads us to the question,
well, how have the residents
of Baddawi Refugee Camp responded
to this imminent catastrophe?
Well, indeed refugees in
Lebanon, like other displaced
and dispossessed people around the world,
have drawn on longstanding
traditions of mutual aid
and of solidarity to
seek and to enact ways
to protect themselves and
others from the pandemic
and I'll turn now briefly
to some of those responses.
So the first example that I'll dwell on
is from March, 2020.
So this is more or less coinciding
with politicians declarations
that camps are dangerous spaces
and that camps should be closed off
and that curfew should be
imposed by the government
and enacted by Lebanese security forces,
which did in fact take
place across the country
but on the 22nd of March last year,
Baddawi Camp's Joint
Security Forces Committee,
in addition to the Popular Committee
and the Mosques Committee,
jointly announced
that a curfew would be enforced
on the camp's residents and businesses
and unlike previous
curfews and camp lockdowns,
of which there have been many
since the camps establishment
in the 1950s, this curfew wasn't imposed
by Lebanese authorities
asserting that the camps
are sites of danger,
instead, because COVID-19
cases had been confirmed
in a neighboring area,
Baddawi Camp activists
in fact, lobbied for the
camps entrances and exits
to be closed in order to
help protect camp residents.
And Baddawi as in other
displacement and hosting contexts,
refugee camps are not isolated spaces
but instead are intimately
connected to urban
and non-urban areas beyond
the boundaries of the camp.
So although Palestinian camps
have often been perceived
as islands of insecurity
to use Rose Misaya's term,
in this context, many camp
residents promptly identified
the risks that existed outside of the camp
and worked to encourage people
to remain within their homes.
So a second example of
camp-based responses,
relates to information.
So UNRWA had been perceived
as being very slow
to inform camp residents
about the risks of COVID-19
and had also been perceived
as being very slow
to provide different forms of support.
So members of the Palestinian
Cultural Club in Baddawi Camp,
the Baddawi Camp Cultural
Club as I'll refer to it now,
they promptly took action,
drawing on that intimate
knowledge of camp life
and of everyday needs
and rights in the camp
to adapt to existing evidence-based
informational posters
including World Health
Organization materials,
translating them into Arabic
and sharing these posters
and other forms of guidance
in print and via social media
to reach camp residents
of all demographics
in an accessible manner.
In addition to running special programs
on it's radio station,
the cultural club worked
with social media networks
that have been established
locally for years,
these networks previously had
been used to inform residents
about everything from school
closures, to which areas
of the camp should be
avoided during armed clashes
or sporadic shootings.
Now, coronavirus at this
stage had not entered the camp
but there was a very strong recognition
that although it wasn't visible or audible
in the way that these armed
clashes and sporadic shootings
had been in the past,
that it was an equally
significant existential threat
to residents in the camp.
So this sharing of information
was, was very important
from that perspective.
By April, they also
increasingly focused on food,
which of course is an essential resource
and many camp residents
have for a very long time
in the camp, tried to make
sure that its diverse,
that the camp's diverse
residents receive enough food
at different junctures of their lives.
And over the past few years
in preparation for the
Holy month of Ramadan,
Palestinian residents,
including members of the cultural club,
have collected financial
donations from other Palestinians
to prepare Iftar food
baskets to break the fast
during the month of
Ramadan, to be distributed
to residents identified
as especially in need,
whatever their nationality.
So Palestinian, Syrian,
Iraqi, Kurdish or Lebanese,
and irrespective of their place of origin.
In 2020, given the fears and
the restrictions on movement
which arose due to the pandemic,
the organizers of these
food baskets were concerned
that it would not be safe
for large numbers of people
to go door to door, collecting donations
or to work together shopping
for ingredients, cooking
and subsequently distributing
hot meals during Ramadan.
But nonetheless, the number
of people in need of food,
has been much larger
than in previous years,
not just because of the pandemic
but also due to the ongoing collapse
of the already fragile Lebanese economy.
So the camp was able to receive donations,
sourced from the camp itself
and from the neighboring areas,
started by distributing food
boxes because of this concern
that it wouldn't be safe to congregate
and to prepare food and
then distribute it together
but then realized increasingly,
that for many people
who would particularly benefit
from receiving these food baskets,
that they may not in
fact have the resources
to be able to cook the
food, they might not have
the cooking equipment, they
might not have fridges,
access to electricity or
cooking stoves, et cetera,
to be able to cook this.
So the decision was made
to enact food preparation
in a safe manner and to
subsequently distribute food
through respecting social
distancing measures
as far as possible.
So they adapted to this changing situation
and expanded preexisting
"Ramadan Basket" initiative
to ensure that the largest
number of people in the camp
were able to access
these, these food baskets.
But just a few days before
the start of Ramadan
on April 23rd, as the
limits of local resources
became increasingly apparent,
the Baddawi Camp Cultural Club chapters,
well, the chapter in Baddawi
but also the cultural club
chapter in Mar Elias Camp,
joined an emergency relief fundraiser,
in partnership with a center
in Burj al-Barajneh Camp
and also two US-based
Palestinian initiatives,
the Palestinian Youth Movement
and The Palestine Rights
to Return Coalition
and their aim was to raise $50,000, to buy
and distribute packages of
food and sanitizing products
in order to help residents
of those three camps;
Baddawi, Mar Elias and Burj al-Barajneh
to be able to practice social distancing
and offset some of the economic damage,
which had been caused by the pandemic
and within three months,
this initiative had exceeded that goal.
That international collaboration
was also supplemented
with the cultural clubs initiative,
which was a "Who Will Donate
a Million?" fundraising drive
which was broad, broadcast on
their social media channels
and on the internet.
Now, of course as I'm talking
about this, it's an important,
it's very important to note
that need and vulnerability
do not simply arise
because of displacement
but rather to remind ourselves
that precarities produced
and is not inevitable.
So vulnerability to shocks and crises
will increase over time and
increase due to different crises
including the spiraling crisis
of Lebanon's financial system.
So here we have some of
the key dates which exist
or coincide with the arrival
of, of COVID 19 in, in Lebanon
with bank transfers and bank
withdrawals being suspended
in March, 2020, the
closure of Beirut Airport
and the devaluation of the Lebanese Lira,
all meaning that people were
unable to access, access money,
if they had access to,
previously had access
to bank accounts, they were
unable to receive remittances
from relatives and
friends outside of Lebanon
and whatever money they
did have access to,
was increasingly unable
to purchase the goods,
which themselves were
also limited in supply
for different reasons.
So here we see that the risk
of people becoming destitute
and starving is because of
policies and political decisions,
not just because of
displacement as it were.
And ultimately, social
distancing is impossible
for people who live in
overcrowded conditions,
who have no savings to draw on to buy food
and whose survival is contingent
on precarious daily labor
in the informal sector.
And indeed in Lebanon,
national authorities
have long prohibited
Palestinian and Syrian refugees
from entering the formal labor
market and that leaves them
amongst the people least
likely to be able to afford
to practice social distancing,
therefore putting them
at higher risk of contracting the disease.
So with this brief chronology
that I'm going through,
in fact, by June, 2020,
there were these diverse
camp-based activities
and camp-led activities,
which had been taking place
in Baddawi Camp but at this point,
no Palestinians in Lebanon
had yet been confirmed
as contracting or having contracted COVID.
But unfortunately on
21st of June last year,
state-run National News Agency reported
that municipal testing of Syrian refugees
working in Tripoli's port, had indicated
that a number of Syrians
who lived in Baddawi Camp
and on the camp's outskirts
had tested positive.
And at this stage, UNRWA representatives
in conjunction with
these media declarations,
indicated that the camps confirmed cases
marked a significant tipping
point for the whole country
and one UNRWA representative stated,
"The epidemic no longer
just threatens our camps,
it has now entered them".
So at this stage, we witnessed
discriminatory processes
including nationality-based
testing systems
and these processes led
to UNRWA officials implicitly asserting
that the previously clean
Barajneh camps, (mumbles) Camp,
was now at risk due to
the Syrians infections.
So Syrian refugees were
identified by the authorities
and by the media as the vector of disease
and in turn, local actors in the camp
including Palestinian factions
and the Popular Committee,
announced that they had
identified the location
of the two Syrians living
quarters within Baddawi Camp
and marked them as the
epicenter of contagion risk
within the camp.
At this time, contact tracing
was immediately set in motion
under the supervision of
the camp's health committee
and the Lebanese Ministry of Health,
which had committed to
transferring any individuals
who tested positive to a state hospital.
But as these developments unfolded,
some camp residents started
to associate COVID-19
with Syrians in line with
the xenophobic rhetoric
that had been used by Lebanese politicians
at the onset of the pandemic.
And amid the raising, the rising fear
of the arrival of the virus,
members of the popular and
the security committees,
started roaming the alleyways
and the streets of the camp,
instructing people to shutter their shops
and to stay indoors
and Baddawi Camp was once
again subjected to closure,
a space under community in quarantine.
Again, this is a good point to,
to step back and to remember
that local responses
developed in Baddawi Camp,
including those funded
locally and those supported
through transnational
networks, demonstrate the ways
that camp residents
have worked individually
and collectively to find
ways to care for Palestinian,
Syrian, Iraqi, Kurdish and
Lebanese residents alike,
therefore transcending a focus
on nationality-based identity markers.
And yet, such modes of
solidarity and mutuality
have been placed at risk
precisely due to national
and municipal interventions
that align with policies
and with political discourses
that have constituted the refugee "Other"
as the threatening carrier
of disease and risk.
So in essence, tensions
and hostility are produced,
not inevitable.
So the final example that I'll give now
of refugee-led responses
arises in the context
of the aftermath of the
devastating August, 2020 blast
in Beirut's port, which
I referred to earlier
and this coincided
with the Coronavirus infection
rates soaring across Lebanon
and with medical infrastructure nationwide
being under mounting pressure.
So in autumn 2020, all of the Red Cross
and Red Crescent
hospitals in North Lebanon
started to relocate with medical
staff either being laid off
or moving to Beirut
in order to care for both blasts survivors
and for the rising number
of COVID-19 patients
in the Capitol.
And although, although
that focus on Beirut
is very understandable,
given the vast destruction
caused by the port explosion,
allocating more resources to the Capitol
has put people living
elsewhere in the country
at greater risk, citizens
and refugees alike.
So recognizing the increasing pressure
on medical infrastructure
and the national, amidst
this national emergency
and as infection rates and
deaths started to increase
in Baddawi Refugee Camp, the
Baddawi Camp Cultural Club
approached local officials
in the town of Baddawi
in August to ask if they could use
one of the municipalities ambulances
in order to take refugees with
COVID symptoms to hospitals
and the municipality grant its approval,
loaning the company ambulance
that was not being used
at that time.
So a member of the Baddawi
Camp Cultural Club volunteered
to collect people who have
suspected COVID-19 infections
from both Baddawi Camp and
also the neighboring camp,
Nahr el-Bared and volunteered
to transport them to hospitals
in Tripoli and in Nahr
el-Bared in some cases,
to the Rafik Hariri Hospital in Beirut,
where the majority of COVID
cases have been cared for.
So this Palestinian refugee driver,
if we want to use that
term, wears a hazmat suit
and protective gear
which have been provided by the Red Cross
and by the Red Crescent
Society at the club's request,
masks have been bought
from local supermarkets
and from shops, both in the
camp and from neighboring areas
and by borrowing this
ambulance, the cultural club
has been using what we would
call or what Yousif and I call
the, "using the citizens tools
in order to assist other refugees".
Now in doing so, the,
the camp's cultural club
and its members, have
continued to improvise
with the limited available resources
to navigate entrenched
inequitable systems.
Such makeshift measures
however, are not sustainable
and there are no substitute
for the health care resources
that national and local
governments should be allocating
to the camps during this crisis
to protect both their residents
and the surrounding communities.
So our interlocutors
have consistently noted
that they celebrate the extent
to which the local responses
have been developed
but they also reassert that
these are not sustainable
and that in fact, more
pressure needs to be applied
to ensure that the structural inequalities
that prevent people
from being able to enact
their own decisions
and to be able to protect their own lives,
those structural barriers
need to be challenged
and that more equitable
systems need to be developed
to provide people with
access to, meaningful access
to medical supplies, medical care,
in addition to fair access to
the labor market, for example.
So these are structural issues
that need to be focused on.
So in conclusion, documenting or archiving
following use of Qasmiyeh's
term, these local responses
is a vital means of stressing the ways
that people who have been displaced,
themselves seek to fill the
gaps and to redress inequalities
that have been created and reproduced
by national and
international actors alike.
And well before COVID-19
arrived in Lebanon,
mutual aid initiatives in Baddawi Camp
and of course elsewhere,
had transcended
nationality-based identifiers
to provide support to camp residents
with wide-ranging backgrounds
in turn highlighting the
importance of critically examining
the ways that preexisting
support systems and networks
are being affected both
by the virus itself
and by the different policies
and politics emerging
in the context of the pandemic
including nationality-based
testing and overlapping crises
such as the Beirut blast.
So ultimately, discourses and policies
that demarcate the sanctity of the "Self"
through the denigration of the "Other",
heighten the dangers of
politically-produced precarity
while undermining the
potential for solidarity
in times of overlapping precarities
However, individuals, communities
and civil society groups
continue finding and implementing
those makeshift measures
which aim to fill the gaps
which have been created
by national and
international actors alike.
And in essence, we cannot understand
either the vulnerabilities that
people face in displacement
or the responses that they are developing
without considering the
ways that local experiences
of and responses to
displacement and other crises,
are framed by national
and international systems
including longstanding
structural inequalities
and processes of
marginalization and exclusion.
So the vulnerabilities that
the residents of Baddawi Camp,
Palestinians and Syrians
alongside Iraqis, Kurds
and Lebanese are facing, are
caused by political failures
that have deep historical roots
and whose repercussions will
continue to be palpably felt
in both the near and the distant future.
So thank you again so much for listening
and I'm very much looking
forward to our conversations
and our discussions, I hope
we've got enough time now
for some exchange and I'd
also like to encourage you
to please join our
communities of conversation,
both on the Refugee Hosts platform
and on the Southern Responses
to Displacement platform,
both of whose contact details
you can see on the slide here
which we'll just leave up for a moment
and then I will stop sharing the screen
and come back to see all of you now.
So thank you again so
very much for listening.
Thank you.
- Yes, so thank you very much,
so I don't know if you have questions,
you're welcome to either
put them on the "Chat"
or
ask directly.
- So thank you very much
for, for highlighting
the structural constraints that exists
on everybody's responses.
I was really quite kind
of interesting, interested
in how, the degree to which,
for instance, young people lead the charge
in changing the world,
so the example that you gave
of the driver for instance,
is that a younger driver
that
decides to, to move forward, for instance?
Have you had any kind of like insight
into any generational engagement
if you don't mind me asking?
I know it's an off the wall question
but I'm really kind of interested
in how young people
themselves just either step up
or
how, yeah, how, like
maybe they, they start,
they step up to change the
world or refuse to do so,
depending on the generation.
- Absolutely, thanks Catherine.
So in the case of the
Baddawi Camp Cultural Club,
it is a youth organization,
so it's an organization
that caters for young people in the camp
but a large number of the
people who organize events,
et cetera, are themselves
UNRWA teachers or UNRWA staff,
who are dissatisfied
with the extent to which
UNRWA itself is able
or willing to address particular
gaps and therefore takes it
as a responsibility to, to fill those gaps
in different ways,
so here we have young people
certainly, being very active
but also working in collaboration
with members of the, of the community
who wouldn't traditionally
be conceptualized
as part of the younger
generation let's say,
so there are different age
groups working together
and there are also different
initiatives taking place.
So here I focused in, on,
on the, on the cultural club
but there are also different
initiatives taking place,
including through, through the mosque,
which again would, through
the many mosques in the camp,
which again would typically
be older generation,
whereas through the camp cultural club,
we have women and men working together
from different generations
to identify what some
of these gaps would be,
whether it's information,
food, financial resources,
sanitation products or stepping
in to provide those medical,
medical resources or access
to those medical resources.
I'm looking forward to delving
a little bit more deeply
into these questions, as
you know, with (mumbles)
and many other colleagues,
we've been looking
at local-led responses to displacement
over the course of four years
and then fortunately, COVID
has hit us right at the end of the project
but it really draws out the extent
to which members of of the
camp community of all ages,
of all professions and of non,
take different responsibilities
and make different decisions
on how to respond to these
overlapping precarities.
I haven't answered your question
very clearly but thank you.
- Sorry, I have a question, Elena
and thank you for your presentation.
I'm speaking from Australia
and I, I'm very familiar
with the Asia Pacific kind
of refugee-led initiatives,
I've been involved in, in some
of the more strategic advocacy work
that refugee leaders
have been involved in.
And I'm wondering in your context,
how much the local level
responses are filtering up
to sort of the national
level decision-making,
is there any access by
refugee-led organizations
to any of that sort of
decision-making beyond the camp
but actually where the
decisions are being made
by Red Cross, for example,
in the humanitarian
coordination sort of system
and any comments you have
about the politics of that I
guess, from your experience.
So thank you.
- Thank you, Louise, thank you.
This kind of comes back to
Catherine's comment as well,
to what extent younger people
want to change the world
or where, where they see their forum
and their sphere of action.
So for many different
reasons, the cultural club
doesn't have access and probably
isn't really seeking access
to governmental systems, for example
and as I mentioned with
quite a lot of UNRWA staff
actually being involved in the activities,
it's almost identifying the
failures in the, in the system
and saying, "Well, what
can we do to fill the gaps
that are not only left by the system
but often are actually created
by the systems themselves?"
So I think this comes back
to that broader question
of kind of division of labor
and division of the gaps
and where different people feel
that they can fill those gaps,
often on through horizontal cooperation.
So one of the initiatives
that I highlighted there,
yes, has transnational support
from US-Palestinian initiatives
but is also working with
other camp-based youth groups,
so whether it's the
Mar Elias Cultural Club
or the Burj al-Barajneh
Youth Center working together
to identify what are the common struggles
that we're facing across the camps
and how can we work together
with that transnational support
to support the, the residents
of these camps situations.
Of course, there are many
other people who do want
to have access to those systems
and those structures of power
and who will be applying for jobs
and who will be lobbying
NGOs and the organizations
that they have access to
but the opportunities are
certainly not coordinated
and supported in the way that
refugee-led organizations
are increasingly having a platform
in specific UN, governmental
and NGO initiatives.
But we go back to that question
of whose voices are heard
and how to, what extent is
it a strategic incorporation
or actually a challenge to the status quo
and really offering an
alternative mode of operating
which doesn't just perpetuate
the humanitarian system itself.
So
I'm really looking forward to hearing more
about the, the Asia
Pacific kind of examples
and how that does or doesn't challenge
those systems themselves
and your work is really
important in that Louisa,
thank you.
- Just, I'm just struck by
the tension of the refugees
who are showing that they are capable,
that they are able to offer
the solutions to problems
that they're not simply a social burden
and yet not wanting to
aggrandize themselves
to the point where it's
sort of like and so,
there isn't still this
existing, incredible inequality.
In other words, that, that's
attention that I found
in my own field work in Greece as well,
where refugees are saying,
"Yes, we are, we can do it
but also this is an impossible task".
And I just, you started to
sort of talk a little bit
about that towards the end
and I just wanted to
get more, I don't know,
ethnographic grounding in what
your, some of the specifics
if you could give us some,
so that I love the image
that you had of the cords
all wrapped around this stick
and you just, people are so creative
and yet it's so fundamentally
unfair and wrong
the way resources are shared or hoarded.
- Yeah, absolutely and as you
say, your research in Greece
demonstrates this remarkably clearly.
So this is a tension I think that arises
in so much of our research,
where we, we recognize,
of course the agency that people have
and we, in my case, want to document
the work that people are
doing and they are resisting
and they are archiving their own responses
and they're doing the research
and they're demonstrating
their capabilities to conceptualize
and to develop different
systems, et cetera, et cetera,
not just to survive and to stay alive,
that's not the basis of, of their actions
and yet at the same time, this recognition
that, it's not sustainable.
So if you think about
the, the image that I had
of people from Nahr el-Bared,
these are internally displaced refugees,
hosted by other refugees,
now hosting refugees.
If we recognize displacement
as being part of this
always already being in
the middle of displacement,
then it's thinking through,
well, what are the political
foundations for that crisis,
those crises, the overlapping precarities
and how do we in fact need
a deeply political response
to this rather than the
constant de-politicization
of humanitarian crisis
as if another plaster is
going to really fix it.
So I think that it goes back
to what, I think that
Catherine was identifying
that I was stressing on the structural
and I think that I am
stressing on the structural,
precisely because of that
tension in my own research
that I don't want to
suggest that, that the US
or that the UN has the right to withdraw
and to say, "We don't have
to be involved anymore,
we don't have a responsibility
'cause look, people are
doing it themselves",
which is effectively one of the
tensions of the localization
of aid agenda, saying,
"Yes, local communities
are doing this,
municipalities can do this"
but they need the
relevant forms of support,
not an abrogation of responsibility.
So for me, it's that
combination of documenting
what, archiving what people
are always already doing
but highlighting that
this is not sustainable,
precisely because it's,
if it's not gonna be COVID
and it's not gonna be the Beirut blast,
it's going to be something else
and you can't expect people
to continue carrying that
without addressing those
structural inequalities.
I'm not giving you any ethnographic detail
in that response Zareena
but I know that you, you
have done so much research
in this area as well
and I think it's more,
it's more that tension,
even what's the ethics,
what are the ethics
of even documenting what people are doing?
How does that play into and
potentially reproduce the system
of abrogating responsibility,
when these are intrinsically
political contexts?
- It's an unfair question
because honestly it's something
I myself have not resolved
in my own work of not
wanting to kind of idealize
this incredible resistance,
without kind of that kind
of hard-hitting critique
and I think you do, I learn
from you always, Elena
'cause you do it I think very
effectively here and elsewhere
where you really do
manage to keep us thinking
about both scales.
- [Elena] That's really kind
of used Zareena, thank you.
- Can I just jump in there?
And I think, I mean, I'm
really loving this conversation
but I think that's maybe
what I was interested in
in terms of that structural
'cause I agree completely
with (murmurs) and I recognize
in the organizations that I work with here
in the Asia Pacific, the
same, the same themes
and the same frustrations
and the same sort of
you're wanting to highlight
what they do because in
some ways it's breathtaking,
like really creative and wonderful
but other times it's so frustrating
to think that how much work is
and how much really hard work
is done to try and even
get mega things happening.
So my question is really,
how do we change the systems
as well as recognize the strengths
and I think that how the strategically
and not in, and I think
you're right, Elena
in terms of like, is it
really representation
and what does it look
like and who's speaking
and all those sorts of things
which are very complicated
and is it actually shifting anything?
But that's my real
question is how do we take
what is done at a local
level and also change systems
and recognize that we don't
want to shift responsibility
but bring people into
that picture, so anyway.
- Thank you, Louise and
absolutely, I don't think
that I have the solution, certainly
but I'm also not sure that
I should have the solution,
that's exactly the point,
is that it shouldn't be me
in Oxford, in the UK saying,
"This is what the UN should do"
but rather actually,
well, how do we listen?
How do we actually stop
and listen and deconstruct
and actually start an open
and equitable conversation
around this with the people
who are not just affected communities,
they are always already responding
and the humanitarian system
often undermines those responses
but won't accept that
because it's also part of
the survival of the system,
which has at its core,
the foundation or the aim
of improving people's lives.
But I think that that,
that's the ongoing work,
it's how to open up those
equitable conversations
in a way that is willing
to, to challenge the systems
and we can go around in circles on it
but I'm, I'm not the
right person to answer it
and, but neither is necessarily one person
from Baddawi Refugee Camp,
it's how we actually join up those dots
and how we have perhaps those examples
of horizontal conversations
and seeing what works
and, what works to destabilize
as well as what works to, to construct.
I think Paul had a question...
- Yes, hi Elena, thank
you for the presentation,
I joined late, I couldn't
actually connect,
I'm in Lebanon now and
actually I, we went through,
me and my family through the Beirut blast.
However, I don't wanna go there
because that's, that's a, that
would be a long discussion.
I'm currently finalizing
my PhD at the UCL,
I'm a UCL, Yale scholar
and my ethnographic studies
and my investigation is
about Syrian refugees.
So I know that they are very marginalized,
I know that to some findings,
that some bottom-up approaches
were successful in a way,
even if temporary
to,
let's say, strengthen the ties
between host community
members and senior refugees.
However, when I visited
and I actually have a paper about that
and I did some ethnographic
studies on the Dbayeh Camp,
where you have Palestinian
and then Syrian refugees were recently,
I mean, they recently
joined after the crisis,
the camp is, is there over 50 years.
And the same thing for Ein El Hilweh.
I saw and I noticed through the interviews
that Syrian refugees over there
are even marginalized
by Palestinian refugees.
So there is like
refugees-to-refugees marginalization,
which actually was an interesting finding.
So the question is
because you're an expert
in that, more investigating
the Syrian refugees,
so the question is, have
you found or noticed
any bottom-up approaches or any mechanisms
between Palestinian and Syrian
refugees within those camps
to strengthen the, or let's
say lessen the marginalization
between the two parties?
For example, this, this club
that you just mentioned,
does it include Syrian refugees?
Thank you.
- Thank you very much, Paul
and I wish that UCL were open
so that we could meet and
have the conversation there
but thank you for, thank
you for your question.
So absolutely, as, as Zareena was saying,
in my research I don't
mean to idealize responses
from Baddawi Refugee Camp
or any of the other places
where I speak with people and
listen to what they're saying
but rather to explore
those complex relationships
and what it means to actually
focus on the relationship
between Palestinians and Syrians
or Palestinians and Kurds,
Palestinians and Iraqis and
the multiple directionalities
of displacement and hosting
that exist in these situations.
And certainly in my broader research,
I do document and explore
different instances
of marginalization, of
discrimination and of exclusion,
so that's certainly part and
parcel of, of those processes.
There are many different
initiatives that do recognize that
and explicitly attempt to
promote social cohesion
in that lovely NGO language,
but also go beyond that
and think through, well, we're
all residents of this space
and if we take the neighborhood
or the camp as the core,
then it's everybody who's in this space
who is a member of this organization
or who is involved in this
particular initiative.
And there, there are many,
many different local responses
which embody that
and which attempt to
challenge the discrimination.
As I was suggesting in
my presentation today,
discrimination, hostility,
tension, isn't inevitable,
it's often produced politically.
So the example that I was
giving from Baddawi Refugee Camp
was of, I'm not sure at
what stage you joined
but nationality-based
testing in Tripoli Port
of Syrian refugees,
identified Syrian refugees
who lived in Baddawi
Camp as carrying COVID-19
and of bringing it into the camp
and of polluting the previously safe camp.
So here it's nationality-based
testing, media reporting,
political declarations,
which leads to the suspicion
of, of Syrians as the epicenter
and as, as the bearers of the disease.
So if we recognize that
tensions, hostility, et cetera,
are produced rather inevitable,
then that's precisely
how it can be challenged
and it can be deconstructed.
And again, Zareena's work in
Greece demonstrates the same,
that you have strange alliances
or what seem to be strange alliances
and Zareena can speak to this
herself, across political
and ideological lines,
from atheist and secular
to faith-based responses, et cetera.
So there definitely is marginalization,
there definitely is discrimination,
just as there is between
different groups of Palestinians,
there's discrimination
between Palestinians
who were born in Baddawi Camp
and Palestinians who've come from Yarmouk
and you can identify where, if
it's a Palestinian from Syria
or a Palestinian from Lebanon
and there are multiple forms of exclusion
and marginalization.
For me, it's recognizing
that it's not inevitable
and that there are multiple
ways of addressing it
but it does come back I
think, to the political
on so many different levels.
And I think it would be great,
Zareena would you like to come in on that
because this is the core
of so much of your research as well?
- Yeah, I mean, I, I love this point
and you know, it seems like
such a simple point to say
that that these conflicts
are produced and not natural
and yet, when we look at
the way that the NGOs think
and the way governments think,
they absolutely treat these
conflicts between refugees
as spontaneous and natural
eruptions in the camps,
rather than things
that are absolutely
produced by structures.
And so, I think as scholar sometimes,
I mean, I certainly have the
feeling where I'm just like,
"This is such a banal point,
should I keep making this point?"
And then I hear Elena make
it so powerfully again
and I say, "Oh my God, yes"
because people don't get
this point, they think
that, I mean, in the camp that
I was working in in Greece,
it was that the strollers go to the Kurds,
before they go to the Afghanis,
before they go to somebody else
and then, Oh, well, why that?
And well my, I had a baby
and I needed a stroller now
who, who decides that?
Why can't it just simply be,
whoever needs a stroller gets a stroller?
What does this invocation
of nationality do?
And I think, I mean, with
the COVID, it's so powerful
to think of the ways in
which they're both...
- [Elena] Thank you, Zareena.
I don't know if we got
cut off just at the end
but thank you.
Paul, what, what do you,
what do you think of that
response or those responses?
- I mean,
the, I mean, it was obvious
that the NGOs are exacerbating
the whole tension within the camp
and within the host community members.
But I was just curious to
see what, what mechanism
could have been done to alleviate that
between Palestinian and Syrian refugees
or other refugees within the camps
'cause I didn't notice that
much of bottom-up approaches
or top-down approaches in
that that were successful.
However, actually based
on, on also my research
regarding COVID-19,
Syrian refugees were
actually marginalized,
I'm talking about the Beqaa area,
this is where my research is.
They were afraid from the
host community members
to be stigmatized and all that
and then actually no cases,
no cases were reported.
So it was the, it was the opposite way
and they, they worked very
well with the municipality,
they were able to coordinate very well,
I mean, the shawish or, I
mean, they were able to find,
to find those internal
structural organizations
that communicate with authorities.
So it was very successful,
I mean, till now
and now we have more cases,
that's, it's a nationwide.
But I didn't see yet any successful,
let's say, mechanisms that that
brought the social cohesion
or social integration.
- Yeah, I think it also
comes back to that question
of when you have to step
in to alleviate something
and then what Zareena and I are suggesting
is that it's actually useful to go back
and to think about how
and why was this produced
to begin with, rather than
assuming that there is a problem
that needs to be fixed by
an external intervention
and, so I think that's,
that's one response
or one thought process that I have
in relation to, to what
you're just saying there.
And then I'm just gonna bring up a slide
from another presentation that I have here
in terms of that notion of success
and what mechanisms might be successful.
So Zareena has seen
this from a presentation
that I gave at Yale a
year, two years ago now.
So this notion of what is
visible and what is undisclosed.
So a lot of our initiatives,
sorry, a lot of the initiatives
that we've been documenting
are kind of below the
radar to a certain extent,
so here what I call the
"poetics of undisclosed care"
are documented through these
three interview extracts,
"So we collected clothes, we offered food
and cash to refugees but I
hope you don't mention this
except for reasons
related to your research
because we do this only for God's sake".
So that's a resident of Baddawi
Camp from Nahr el-Bared.
A Syrian refugee living in Baddawi Camp,
"Those people who offer assistance
without disclosing their
names deserve respect"
and a Kurdish refugee from
Syria, living in Baddawi Camp,
"Be like the good fruit that gives...",
sorry, "Be like the good
tree that gives its fruits
and does not ask who took them".
So how do we think about
what is successful,
what is visible, what is
invisible in these contexts?
And there's definitely
differentiated care,
here's another, another quote here,
"The differential response
to residents of Nahr
el-Bared Camp being displaced
to Baddawi Camp, as opposed
to those displaced from Syria,
something that's very well documented
and kind of discussed within the camp",
again, another example
of differentiated care
and then what I'm looking for
here is what we can think of
as that notion of success,
which is coming back to
that question that you have.
So here is a Syrian who
is living in Baddawi Camp
and they say, "The local
communities here in Baddawi Camp
are also in a deplorable situation
and also suffer from poverty.
They cannot meet their own needs,
how can they provide in-kind
and financial assistance to others?
We only ask them for good treatment
and non-discrimination between refugees
on the basis of their
political affiliations",
which was something
that had been happening
in Baddawi Camp at that time.
"The institutions here are
meant to provide assistance
and we would like them
to provide assistance
in a profession manner."
So this idea of what, what
is considered to be enough,
another interview with
another Syrian in Baddawi Camp
about, which is kind of
picking up on this notion
of caring or observing,
"I think that the biggest
part of the local community
does not care about this and
their role does not transgress
the limits of observing".
So the question that arises
for me is, who determines
what is enough and what is a good response
or not, a not good enough response?
So if we bear in mind the
poetics of undisclosed care
on the one hand, what
is the necessity of care
versus observing, for example?
Is it enough to observe?
This Kurdish refugee from
Syria says, "It is enough
that they allowed us to live amongst them,
despite this great population pressure.
In my view, the local
community is not interested
in providing us with assistance,
all they have to do is accept
our presence in these areas
and to offer us moral support.
For me, it is enough
that my Palestinian neighbor
greets me every morning
and that I go to work, being
sure that my children are well
amongst their foreign neighbors".
So it's not a response
but it's a question,
who decides what is enough, who decides
if it's material support,
if it's spiritual support,
if it's greeting somebody in the alleyway,
sharing that space, ensuring
that the children are well
amongst their foreign neighbors?
Is being with or being together enough,
from whose perspective and
how do we counteract that
when we think about how NGOs come in
and say that what we
need is social cohesion
and what we need is this kind of response,
this is what success looks like?
Well, actually, what does it look like
from conditions of structural precarity?
What does it look like
from, from the perspective
of different people within the camps?
And that's not to say that the,
I agree that that's enough,
I might have an idealized
vision of what would work better
but it's a more complex process,
I think, than identifying,
this is the right
mechanism, this is success,
success according to whom,
success according to what
markers of visibility and action?
I think, that's some of
the questions that I have
as I'm continuing to go, to read through
the interview transcripts that we have
and bearing in mind the
ethnographic research
that myself and my teams
have been doing as well.
So it will be really
fascinating to hear more
about your research as it,
as it continues to develop.
So thanks for that question
and that conversation
and it's really lovely to be
able to have that discussion
and that exchange.
Thanks, Paul.
- I have a question, Elena,
it's like, what have
been like the implication
or what you have seen
in terms of gender differences basically,
some of the marginalization of women
that you have seen before,
how that has changed now
or, I mean, what directions
with the pandemic?
And the other thing is about now
in terms of the vaccinations
because I guess that even,
I guess in every country we're seeing now
sort of some groups being put
like at the end of the queue.
So how you have seen that basically
from the, a country that
is most likely stretched
in terms of vaccinating its own citizens,
how,
well, the xenophobic views
are probably reinforced there
in term, with, with the
vaccination now (murmurs)?
- Great, thank you, Teresa.
So I haven't looked
specifically at gender dynamics
with reference to COVID,
I've, I haven't been able
to be in Baddawi Camp
obviously for a long time,
so it's kind of, it's all from a distance,
suddenly there are
longstanding unequal roles
played by women with
reference to the destruction
of particular key services in
a, in a space like Baddawi,
so if we think about school closures,
so women are actively involved
in educating their children
and supporting their learning
with often multiple children
of different ages, attempting
to access online learning
through the one mobile phone
or the radio system
that might possibly be giving them access,
so their domestic burdens are increasing,
their educational provision,
attempting to keep people safe and clean,
so all of those duties
are enhanced precisely
because of the pandemic,
the ability to, to make due
with very small amounts of food available,
how you change your entire
domestic framework around cooking
and keeping your safe and
healthy and fed, et cetera,
they're all key issues,
large numbers of women
who are formal educators as well
and therefore are teaching
just as many of us are teaching
plus looking after our
families at home, et cetera.
And the impact
of the reduction of
informal labor opportunities
obviously leaving men in
particularly vulnerable positions
to exploitation as well,
which has certainly been
documented in, in many instances.
So Syrian refugees, for example,
who were already male refugees,
who were already at risk
of detention, deportation,
expulsion, et cetera,
are even more at risk now
precisely because of curfews,
because of lockdowns,
because of those people who
are or don't have the privilege
of remaining in doors
and being, respecting
social distancing rules,
being more visible in the public sphere
and therefore more at risk.
So I think there are
different, different ways
in which gender relations
have been affected
and particular gender vulnerabilities
have been accentuated by, by COVID-19.
With reference to vaccinations in Lebanon
and I'm sure that Paul
will be able to give us
kind of more up-to-date briefing
from Beirut perspective,
I think a lot of us were very
concerned that Palestinians
and Syrians would be excluded
from the vaccination rollout
but in fact, shortly after
the Lebanese politicians
were first vaccinated in the country,
vaccines were reaching UNHCR
and UNRWA distribution points,
so Palestinian refugees
have and Syrian refugees
have been able to
register for vaccinations,
there has been quite a bit of reticence
amongst Lebanese citizens, so
although there has been a push
to vaccinate Lebanese citizens,
the uptake potentially hasn't been as high
as many would have
expected and there's been
a particular buyout system
to ensure that UN systems
were able to purchase
and distribute those vaccines.
So thankfully, there
has been a recognition
that the public health crisis
requires vaccination of all
and this has not immediately
materialized as discrimination
against Palestinian, Syrian,
Iraqi, Kurdish refugees
accessing the vaccine,
so there is a rollout,
we'll have to see how
that, how that continues
but in, in this case, a relatively small,
so of course the per
capita ratio of refugees
per citizen capita, is
very high in Lebanon
but the overall population
is relatively small
when compared with many other countries,
so the capacity to actually rollout
is hopefully going to be,
well, we can only hope
that it's going to, going to work
in a broadly equitable framework.
So maybe we'll have a better idea of that
in a couple of weeks, where,
what are we, three, four weeks
post the arrival of
the vaccine in Lebanon,
so it is, it is quite early days.
I'm not sure if Paul,
if you have a, a more
up-to-date account of that.
- I mean, the only update
is like the whole rollout of the vaccine
is, has been a flop by
the Lebanese government.
However, it is, everybody is equated,
so it is open for everybody,
which is actually a good sign
but we as Lebanese citizens
now we feel ourselves
as refugees as well within the system.
So, I mean, when you see that
the deputies of your country
just got vaccinate, the, I
went to the official platform
and everybody is waiting.
So the amount of vaccines that
arrived here is not enough,
it's very low, but yes, the
good thing is that everybody,
not only, not only through
vaccinations actually,
everybody can be admitted
to hospitals if needed,
the Hariri State Hospital,
whether you're Lebanese,
Syrian or Palestinian
but the vaccination is now
it's, it's, it is a flop
and it is within the corrupt
system of the government.
- Do we have any more
questions or comments
or points of conversation?
- I think probably I would
like to just mention,
I mean, with respect to the vaccination
in a completely different
setting in Latin America
with the Venezuelan refugees,
that actually the...
because
non-registered Venezuelans
do not have access
to the, for example the
Columbian healthcare system,
the need to vaccinate them just brought
basically a legalization program now
of around 1 million people,
of 1 million refugees.
So just, I mean, at least
in terms of the offer
and even if the supply is
flow for, for everybody
because the vaccination
program is, just started
as well as in Lebanon, so at least...
and that was completely political,
well, not completely political decision
because the first reaction
was not to vaccinate the refugees
but there was like an outcry
and then that brought to the change.
So
I guess probably that
perspectives sort of reassurance
in that,
that behavior but maybe as you say,
maybe working, I mean, see
what is the uptake as well
because
even, I mean, in all the
countries we have seen also
from minorities in general
so, of a bit of low
take up of the vaccines.
- Yeah, absolutely
and the extent to which,
for example, in the UK
there are grave concerns
that with the hostile environment
pervading medical settings
that people who have irregular
status will, will not risk,
they won't risk having prenatal
or birthing assistance,
they won't attend for
vaccinations for their infants,
let alone will they expose themselves
potentially to detention and deportation
on the basis of, of accessing
COVID vaccine, vaccines.
So absolutely the hostile environment,
the criminalization of people
with different legal backgrounds creates,
again, creates these inequalities
and creates these, these
public health issues,
so we can, we can only hope
there are increasing countries
which are ensuring that there
is access, vaccination access
for people with, with refugee backgrounds.
But I was seeing and Yvonne
might, might speak to this,
in Canada for example,
the adverts that are being circulated,
Catherine Clark Kazakh has been
discussing this on Twitter,
refers to, "all Canadians are
eligible for the vaccine",
which excludes people who
aren't necessarily citizens.
So even how the terminology is used,
who is included or excluded,
when in fact migrants
and refugees are eligible for the vaccine
but the terminology that is being used
is exclusion, is excluding people.
And as I said, I don't know
if Yvonne has any comments
from her own research as
well or from her reflections
on the situation in Canada.
- [Yvonne] Yes, thanks Elena,
for speaking about that.
Yes, there's some discussion of that
and then I think in general,
there's a lot of discourse by
the prime minister of Canada,
Justin Trudeau, about this narrative
of "We're all in this together",
which has upset a lot of people
because of course we understand
that we're not all in this together,
there's a lot of inequalities that exist.
So this type of discourse
has been upsetting people
'cause it's been taking place
also at all different levels
of the government as well.
And in general, a lot
of vaccine confusion.
Everybody is, all over the
news everybody is quite upset
about how it's getting rolled out,
what systems are being used,
people are trying to line up
and that's, that's of no help
'cause they're supposed
to make phone calls,
you make phone calls and
you can't get through
'cause everybody is also on
the line trying to sort it out,
so it, yeah, Canada's not a great example.
- [Elena] Yep, thank you, Yvonne.
Again kind of disrupting the assumptions
that erupted so early
on in the COVID pandemic
that certain countries
would be well-prepared
and the red, the red zones
of where there would be greater crisis
hasn't necessarily corresponded
with that geopolitics
of the imagination of,
of health and infirmity.
- Okay,
so I think we've reached the end
of this conversation,
so thank you very much
for the presentation, Elena
and
yes, if, I guess
we'd like,
to,
yeah,
just to
contact you on this topic or yeah,
and also basically sort of expand
the community of people researching.
So, thank you very much.
- Thank you, Teresa, thank
you all for, for joining
and for staying on.
Thank you,
it's very lovely to
see you all, thank you.